yann moix ya peut-être un moyen ou cher
cyril de sortir de cette impasse
on dit par jour est-ce qu'il faut
distinguer l'homme de l'artiste et bien
moi je veux dire une chose
un artiste ça n'existe pas je ne connais
pas d'écrivain je ne connais que des
hommes qui font des oeuvres je ne
connais que des hommes qui font des
films donc je connais des hommes et des
oeuvres et l'espèce de monstre du loch
ness la créature imaginaire qui entre
l'homme et l'oeuvre sur l'artiste je ne
connais pas je ne sais pas ce que c'est
qu'un réalisateur mais vous explique si
on donne un césar du meilleur
réalisateur si c'est le meilleur
réalisateur alors il a fait le meilleur
film donc oui pour voter pour des
oeuvres et non pour voter pour des
hommes car dans mon réalisateur on
injecte une ambiguïté qui est qu on va
être obligé de juger un homme pareil
pour les acteurs pourquoi ne pas juger
un premier rôle ou un second rôle et non
pas un acteur dans un rôle je vous dis
ça parce que du coup on pourrait
s'interroger sur la chose suivante
un homme est bourré de défauts de tares
de lacunes
il ya des choses qui ont été inventés
pour que l'homme s'arrache à sa propre
médiocrité
il ya l'amour il ya la mort il ya la
religion et ya l'art l'art est une des
manières que l'homme a pour s'extirper
de cette misérable nas de son tas de
secrets misérable comme malraux qui est
lui-même et polanski est un homme sans
doute médiocre mais qui a comme
possibilité de s'extraire à la gravité
de sa propre médiocrité de faire des
oeuvres
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose si vous le permettez cyril c'est
cette histoire de tribunal populaire du
tribunal juridique
pourquoi dans le cas de polanski il est
normal que le tribunal tribunal
populaire continue à devrais je dire
pourquoi quelle est la grande différence
entre un tribunal juridique un tribunal
populaire le tribunal juridique ne juge
pas un homme
il juge les actes car il part du
principe qu'un homme va se racheter
un homme est capable de se racheter et
pourquoi il va se racheter l'homme parce
qu'il a été puni parce qu'il a purgé une
peine
or le problème dans le dans la sphère
paul riquet et c'est pourquoi le pré
tribunal continuait populaire a raison
de continuer c'est qu'on a l'impression
qu'il n'a pas fait et donc il ne peut
pas être meilleur car il n'a pas purgée
et donc cet homme qui peut être
meilleure part d oeuvre ne peut pas
l'être
humainement parce que le tribunal
populaire assez
sentiment que le juridique ne s'est
jamais appliqué et donc la casse à
refaire séquence ion tant qu'il n'aura
pas été jugée juridiquement et bien les
gens considérant que le procès est
encore à venir et donc polanski est
prisonnier sur d'un acte les tribunaux
actuelle habituellement déconnecte
l'acte de l'homme à cause de ce nom
jugement les deux chez lui sont
confondus